surtout ne touchez à rien ne bougeait
pas rester avec nous
dans le reste de l'actualité pour notre
deuxième sujet de l'année qu'est ce que
vous avez retenu
on aimerait travailler sur les jeunes
les grands pays membres à savoir comment
et bible comment ça se passe chez eux
est-ce que vous avez déjà pris des
contacts a contacté à damette darthial
de la cimade pour les ignorants aussi
prévu de suivre envahie s ben vu qu'il
est dans notre classe et là je pense que
son parcours ne peut être intéressant tu
es d'accord au voyage il voit un petit
peu comment ça se passe oui et alors
en route pour notre deuxième reportage
de l'année
r2
[Musique]
et pour mieux comprendre à défaut de
pouvoir imaginer ce que vivent les
jeunes migrants et lee et lucas
accompagné de maria lluis à leurs
copines venues du brésil se rendent dans
les locaux de la cimade l'association
qui fête ses 80 ans accompagne les
migrants dans leurs démarches
administratives
vous savez que quand on habitait son
pays c'est très dur et c'est là où vous
jeunes vous avez un rôle important à
jouer
il faut accueillir vos amis qui viennent
d'ailleurs parce qu'ils ne viennent pas
pour faire du tourisme
ils viennent parce que leurs parents ont
pu fuir quand on arrive dans un pays
dans les circonstances dans lesquelles
ils arrivent avec des passeurs en
troupes
ils ont l'impression qu'ils n'ont aucun
droit ils n'ont que des devoirs et
préférant celui de retourner dans leur
pays
donc on leur dit non vous avez quelques
droits il faut les exercer et puis on
parle des droits de l'homme la
convention de genève des droits de
l'enfant les droits pour tous mais aussi
toujours des histoires singulières
ce jour là l'équipe de reporters est
invité chez l'un des élèves de la classe
moyenne
j'ai préparé un repas traditionnel de
l'ebit sa maman a mis les petits plats
dans les grands pour partager sa culture
et si c'est le bourrique avec l'épinard
est le fromage et les très bons donc
servi vo c'est comme chez vos priorités
la famille est arrivé de tripoli il ya
six ans pour suivre la maman qui avait
obtenu une bourse pour terminer ses
études de dentiste en france depuis leur
pays a sombré dans le chaos
impossible d'y retourner à quelles
difficultés avez vous été confronté
j'arrive pas de d'un secret dans les
universités pour terminer mes études
c'était c'était très compliqué donc à
c'est tout mais pour moi et pour mes
enfants et mon mari en a trente qui
laissait n'y a pas des problèmes et ça
c'est hoyé sont les vies quand je
rentrais
l'école j'avais un peu peur une
adaptation facilité par le passage dans
cette classe une structure nommée eu pe2
art et qui accueille tous les enfants
étrangers à leur arrivée dans le collège
on voyait c'est maria luis a ils ont
appris le français
entre autre scène casque en apprend on
parle le français on apprend à vivre
avec des origines différentes avec des
langues différents après c'est vrai
quand on est ici donc tu dis c'est aussi
un espace un espace d'accueil où on peut
être ensemble une passerelle en fait qui
vous permet petit à petit d'aller dans
votre classe d'être avec les autres
élèves dans toutes les matières est de
comprendre la langue en fait la langue
de l'école moi quand je vois mes élèves
commencé à partir et puis a à me dire
bonjour de loi ben je suis contente de
voir ben voilà ça y est ils sont dans
leur classe quand ils n'ont plus besoin
de moi fut une victoire une victoire
mais aussi parfois la naissance d'un
lien très fort ce jeune lycéen en
témoigne il avait 15 ans quand il est
arrivé seul du mali prise en charge par
des éducateurs est soutenu par
l'enseignante
grâce à madame chenu
je me suis sain team moi même elle me
faisait toute confiance tout le temps
elle me dit que je peux réussir tout le
temps il m'a sauvé la vie il m'a montré
déchets mais déçu mais que judas civ
la confession du jeune homme a
bouleversé nos trois reporters et sans
doute aussi modifier leur regard sur les
copains venus d'ailleurs